in this video we'll talk about the
concept of cell differentiation this is
a fundamental concept in developmental
biology and in this video we would learn
the concepts of specification
determination and commitment
cell differentiation is a process of
generating specialized specialized cell
from a stem cell
so from this particular stem cell it can
ultimately become neuron epithelial cell
or fibroblast via the process of
differentiation during the process of
differentiation the proliferation or the
division process of cell ceases and it
acquires
structural and distinct functional
elements that can govern its property
now the biggest thing about
differentiation is it cannot revert its
identity once it is differentiated
that means after becoming a neuron cell
has to function like a neuron for the
rest of its life one fine day you cannot
find a neuron becoming muscle or neuron
is reverting back to the stem cell
so this is the biggest property of a
differentiated cell that it would
maintain its functional identity for the
rest of its life
but this differentiation process is not
at all easy there are different stages
during this long process so there are
two big stages during differentiation
one stage is known as specification it
is a early stage of the commitment
process
so in this stage
the decision is kind of
changeable that means it is liable
to change
and there are external and internal
influences that can modulate
specification process
differentiation is one of the
complicated process
and the second stage of different
differentiation is known as
determination
determination is a process of commitment
it's a decision point which is
irreversible that means once the cell is
determined to become a particular cell
type it has to become there is no way
out
in this video we will talk about these
steps in bit more detail so let's begin
so the first stage of the commitment
process is known as specification
remember commitment happens before
the differentiation so differentiation
is kind of like an outcome and
commitment is the reason why there would
be a differentiated outcome
so the first step of the commitment is
specification a cell or tissue is said
to be specified when it is capable of
differentiating autonomously
when placed in an environment that is
neutral with respect to our
developmental pathway
and it can differentiate autonomously
then it is known as a specification
so let me explain it with example so
here is a cell and this particular cell
is specified to become a muscle
so eventually if we keep it in the dish
it should become a muscle
another cell type is specified to become
neuron so obviously if we keep it in the
dish in a neutral situation there are
intrinsic drive that would make it a
neuron
so this is known as a specification step
but this particular step is liable to
change for example if you give external
influences such as you take this neuron
cell
and or this muscle cell
and put it in a different environment
for example if you put this muscle cell
with a lot of neurons there could be
influence from these neighboring neurons
and possibly this muscle cell can
eventually become a neuron even if it is
destined to become
muscle at the first place
that means specific specification
process is kind of reversible
it is capable of being altered
so
moral of the story is during the process
of specification external influences
matter a lot
okay the next stage of differentiation
is known as determination it is a more
advanced stage of commitment
and once a cell is determined to take a
fate it cannot reverse
so external influences internal
influences nothing would matter
it has to differentiate
so determination is an advanced stage
and
in this particular stage
the cell has to be
getting influences from external or
internal sources but it won't matter
for example once this particular cell is
determined to be neuron
if you keep it in
proximity with neurons it would still
become a neuron if you keep it in
proximity with muscle
or even if you keep it alone in all of
these cases
it would ultimately become neuron that
means once it is determined its fate
internal external cues would not matter
that much
that's the punch line
so now let's talk about how
differentiated cell is different from a
normal cell
so
a undifferentiated cell and a
differentiated cells are quite different
from various perspective
they could be different from
morphological perspective
obviously a stem cell looks very
different from a neuron
there could be changes in chromatin
landscape gene expression profiles
protein related differentiate different
differences such as like post
translational modifications could be
different there could be epigenetic
changes in simple words there could be
also different regulatory rnas which
drive the
change in gene expression or chromatin
landscape so there are
different different aspects
which could make a differentiated cell
very different from an undifferentiated
or a stem cell but the question is what
is the origin of these differences so
what is the molecular mechanism of cell
differentiation
it is very complicated it is diverse and
there could be several mechanisms
involved
cell involving cell differentiation but
we would look at some strategies to get
a little bit idea
so let's talk about a strategy one
so here is a particular cell
it has two alternative fades one is
let's say becoming an epithelial fit and
the second is becoming a neuron
so there could be master regulators such
as master transcription factor a which
drives the fed towards epithelial cell
there could be also master regulator
transcription factor b which drives the
fate towards neuron
and both these master regulator factors
are actually driven by internal and
external influences
now if you want to take a live example
let us bring a live example from the
immune system so the cd4 positive t
helper cells can get differentiated into
different different sublineages
such as th1 cell th17 cell th follicular
cell th2 cells and all of these cell
types has their different function
distinct molecular identities
so there are external influences such as
specific cytokines
these cytokines influence the process of
determination or differentiation
so these cytokines depend upon which
type of cytokine cocktail is there
determines what master transcription
factor would be activated for example if
interferon gamma and interleukin-12 is
there the master transcription factor t
bet is generated which ultimately give
rise to th1 subtype similarly different
cocktails produce different master
regulator transcription factor
each of these master regulators give
rise to different gene expression
modules which might
lead to differentiation into different
sub lineages
so there are plethora of steps that can
occur
underlying differentiation and it is
fairly complicated
now let's talk about a strategy two
there are multiple strategies we are
only talking about few hand-picked
strategies
now let's say there is a master
regulator one
which give rise to
which is uh
giving rise to a master transcription
factor there is a master regulator two
which is giving rise to another
transcription factor and this is overall
regulated by micro rna x now all these
transcription factors
control specific gene expression modules
now these modules kind of suppress each
other that's why in a stem cell state
none of the fate are chosen
neither fate one or fate two is chosen
because there is a mutual suppression
this is a hypothetical example but
anyway imagine there is a
developmentally regulated micro rna so
in one point of
development this particular micro rna is
predominant and this micro rna binds to
master regulator 2's mrna transcript so
obviously it would
inhibit the production of master
regulator 2.
as a result what happens the gene module
that was controlled by master regulator
2 is now down regulated so the
suppression is removed
now one particular gene module which was
controlled by master regulator 1 would
now dominate
as a result one particular fate would be
chosen
and this is how the fate determination
happens
and these are very few examples that we
have taken there could be epigenetic
modulations there could be chromatin
modulations there could be multiple
modulations
in combinations as well so it is far
more complicated that we can imagine
but anyway
overall there could be epigenetic
influences mrna mediated controls things
can be degraded fast or
mrna can sustain for a very long time
there could be differential gene
expression there could be
transcriptional control there could be
protein degradation control that means
imagine a particular protein to be
present in the initial phase of the
differentiation and eventually it
degrades or let's say
initially the protein is degraded but
beyond a certain point of time in
development the protein stops degrading
and is stabilized
that leads to
the choice of one particular fate over
the other and this is how cell
differentiation take place
so in this video we get an overall idea
there could be also promoter related
changes for example
promoters of differentiated cells are
very different from a stem cell so it
shows different nucleosomal organization
compared to a stem cell
it also shows different histone marks
present in the nucleosomes so for
example in stem cell there is a balance
between activatory and repressive marks
now in a particular differentiated cell
there could be selective activatory
marks or selective inhibitory marks
which are very different the pattern is
very different from a stem cell
or undifferentiated cell and these
combination of factors make one
particular cell different from the other
and that is how
the fate is determined in subsequent
videos we would talk about more uh
details about differentiation process
they are classifications autonomous
non-autonomous phase specification etc
but let me tell you in order to
understand these kind of complicated
process scientists require a combination
of techniques a combination of proteomic
transcriptomic metabolic and multi-ohmic
approach is required to understand
complicated process like differentiation
anyway you must be wondering
why we would learn about differentiation
differentiation is really important for
example
if you know how a cell differentiates
you can generate different cell types
from the stem cell for example you can
produce neuron retinal neurons liver
hepatocytes muscle cells etc
now why that is useful imagine somebody
is undergoing a third degree burn now
obviously this particular person needs a
graft
but eventually there is a huge incidence
of graft rejection
right
so
if this particular person can donate
donate its skin cells
and that skin cell can be converted into
stem cells by specific cocktails and we
know how to make skin cells out of the
stem cells then we can generate skin
graft artificially
and then this particular graft can be
donated to the person with injury now
since this particular cells are coming
from this patient itself there would be
no problem of graph rejection
so the grafting would be more efficient
compared to the traditional method of
grafting
so this is how we can understand why
this kind of cell differentiation or
understanding the
mechanism of cell differentiation is
really important
and this would be
in future be very important for stem
cell replacement therapy
i hope this video was useful you can get
notes and flash card in my facebook page
also you can follow me on instagram all
the links are in description
you can support this channel by clicking
on the super thanks button which is on
the bottom right corner of any video you
can contribute using paytm paypal upi
net banking or any other
payment methods
you can follow us on social media all
our social media links are provided in
the description see you in the next
video